Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
And the Official Legend of Korra Book 4 Trailer
just dropped.
So this is going to be a breakdown of that.
Naturally, it melted my face off.
But let's just start by saying.
Kuvira
Mechs
Fire Nation
Katara
Zuko's Daughter
and Toph!
That's right, someone burned all their Genie
Wishes and they took all the things we loved
from
Books 1 through 3 combined them and threw
in some Last Airbender stuff.
It's going to be amazing!
I will be doing videos for all the episodes.
As well a weekly giveaway.
So be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get everything!
It starts OCT 3rd
So, let's talk about this trailer:
So this Black and White Flashback sequence
is all just Book 3 stuff.
Just rehashing Korra and the way she feels
about herself.
Tenzin's Speech just highlights the fact that,
yes.
She's going to come to the conclusion that
she
is needed.
The Avatar is
still
needed
in
the world.